[Music]
terrible
i feel like i could have given them
slightly bigger measurements
is it appropriate to do this intro with
this thing in the middle of us i
literally make fun of clint like it's
pretty yeah sure why did you put it in
the center of our front door
hey i'm here with casey edward master
composer you may know him from the
internet these stupid songs that we'll
sing sometimes they make us laugh we
want to take that inspiration and we
want to turn it into real music and i'm
gonna take you guys through the process
of what it's like actually making a
short album with our friend casey we're
gonna make music videos to go with them
and then we're gonna release them all at
the same time that's the plan we'll see
if we actually stick to the plan they
say the key to being a good actor is
always be doing something brad pitt you
always seem eating
is this
the real reason why i'm telling you that
is because robert downey jr is also an
actor who plays iron man we just so
happen to have received the iron man
costume courtesy of our friends at the
dash armoryfactory.com thanks guys i
haven't tried any of this on i don't
know if it fits it's a good start moment
oh this is the back
tight squeeze
oh
my performance is off
is my head supposed to go in here
no
way my
kidding me now
i will try this entire suit on
after i eat when i ordered this from
tony he said that it would put itself on
maybe they just forgot to send that part
you got sucked in do you think it's like
how does it go on in iron man
it's all about that
jarvis
[Music]
i need more sandwich
can't connect to the internet [ __ ] this
[ __ ]
so like and connect to the internet [ __ ]
this [ __ ] we just came up with a a hot
track two nights ago called hobos in the
dark hobos in the dark hobo hobos in the
dark
[Music]
yes
put this [ __ ] in there dude
let's make magic
that's right okay i can connect to the
internet and i [ __ ] this [ __ ] when i was
a little boy i didn't have a neck i've
been around too long to know before the
times when i could go on and jam out to
do little reddit could i go out and jam
out to a little youtube
there you go that's a good place to
start yeah
speakers bigger than your head with the
quested v2108s they blow hans zimmers
off funny enough these are actually the
same speakers he uses too
[ __ ] you jarvis
okay so this is all tony stark does okay
oh god
yeah hold it yep okay stop flexing
[Music]
it's like a baby coming out
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i got it this is the worst dude
now i know what binding feed is like
you're supposed to because there's no
[ __ ] way
watch those ears
[Music]
at first i wasn't sure if i wanted to
take on the burden of being iron man but
after a while it began to make sense to
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey man
[Music]
dude no big deal
boom
that's a good looking suit this is how
you know it's good right here
you get that that crackling i'll see you
in the sky
when i first
my first day it's going better than
expected when i first put this thing on
i thought this sucks but then you know
you get the compliments you get the
enthusiasm people really dig iron man
you know tony's done a lot to put in the
reputation and get the name out there
and feel better about the whole
situation even though i can't feel my
neck and can't really feel my toes or my
palms i think i'm going to be good
so hobo's in the dark basically nick and
i it was 2 a.m we were filming in this
alleyway and there was a hobo far down
the alleyway peeking around the side of
the dumpster so we started singing hobos
and the dog hobo hobos in the dog
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we we've got now got scratch tracks
at least reference hooks for two of the
songs this is what's great working with
people like casey because they bring
these sounds in your head
to life i don't know how i was born with
it it's just genius all this allows at
this point
is a jumping off point for lyrics
further additions to the song sweet
[Laughter]
i know that jarvis isn't necessarily
ready and i can't quite fly but tony
said the weapon systems would be ready
so if i just he said all i need to do is
oh
yeah so they work very dangerous so i'm
gonna try those out when i'm in a little
bit of a safer scenario and uh hopefully
master them before i can fly
[Music]
[ __ ] i can't connect to the internet
what am i gonna do